>>> THE NYPD IS LOOKING FOR A
SKATEBOARDER CAUGHT ON
SURVEILLANCE VIDEO DEFACING A
BUST OF GEORGE FLOYD IN
MANHATTAN'S UNION SQUARE.
AS THE SUSPECT RIDES BY ON THE
SKATEBOARD, YOU SEE THERE, HE
SPLASHES GRAY PAINT ACROSS THIS
BUST AND THIS IS VANDALISM THAT
HAPPENED IN BROAD DAYLIGHT,
SUNDAY MORNING, JUST FOUR DAYS
AFTER THE BUST WAS UNVEILED
THERE.
IT IS PART OF A LARGER
INSTALLATION WITH BUSTS OF
BREONNA TAYLOR AND CONGRESSMAN
JOHN LOUIS, THOSE WERE NOT
DEFACED, BUT WERE LEFT AS THEY
WERE.
JOINING ME NOW IS GEORGE FLOYD'S
BROTHER, YOU WERE FIRST PERSON I
THOUGHT OF WHEN I SAW THIS
VIDEO.
AND I JUST WONDER WHAT YOU WERE
FEELING WHEN YOU SAW IT.
>> IT WAS ZPUFTING AND DOWNRIGHT
WRONG.
WE LIVE IN A WORLD WHERE THEY'RE
USING BRUTAL FORCE AGAINST BLACK
DEFENSELESS PEOPLE AND GET YET
THEY'RE USING BRUTAL FORCE
AGAINST BLACK STATUES.
THIS IS A PROBLEM, BUT MY
BROTHER, YOU KNOW, HE TOLD ME
SOMETHING A LONG TIME AGO, YOU
CAN'T SERVE A PURPOSE IN LIFE
WITHOUT SOMEBODY THROWING ROCKS
AT YOU.
BUT IN THIS CASE, IT IS PAINT.
>> AND IT IS NEW, RIGHT?
IT IS NEW AND THIS IS SOMEONE
THAT SO MANY PEOPLE CONNECT WITH
THIS NEW MOVEMENT OF RACIAL
RECKONING IN AMERICA.
IT ALSO COMES ON THE HEELS OF A
NEW YORK TIMES REPORT THAT NINE
NEW YORK CITY FIREFIGHTERS WERE
SUSPENDED FOR RACIST MESSAGES
THAT MOCKED YOUR BROTHER.
WHITE FIREFIGHTERS SHARED RACIST
MESSAGES AND MEMES ON THEIR
PHONES THAT MOCKED HIS DYING
MOMENTS AND THEY GLOATED ABOUT
HOW POLICE COULD LEGALLY SHOOT
BLACK CHILDREN.
HOW DISCOURAGING IS ALL OF THIS
TO YOU AND TO YOUR FAMILY?
>> IT IS TERRIBLE.
YOU THINK ABOUT ALL THE FAMILIES
WHO ARE GOING THROUGH THIS PAIN,
AND THE SUFFERING.
WE DIDN'T ASK TO BE PART OF THIS
FRATERNITY, WE WERE THROWN INTO
IT BECAUSE OUR SIBLINGS WHO WE
LOVE ARE BEING MURDERED IN BROAD
DAYLIGHT, AND IT'S -- THIS IS A
PROBLEM.
AND THIS IS A PROBLEM WITH THIS
COUNTRY.
AND WE NEED TO SOLVE IT.
THERE IS NO WAY THAT WE CAN GET
THROUGH THIS WITHOUT SOLVING IT
BECAUSE IF YOU CONTINUE TO
DESTROY STATUES, IT LETS YOU
KNOW HOW MUCH TIME WE HAVE
BEFORE THEY CONTINUE TO TRY TO
DO SOMETHING TO HARM PEOPLE WHO
ARE ALIVE AND LIVING.
>> ONE OF OUR GUESTS YESTERDAY
REMINDED US THAT EVEN DECADES
AFTER EMMETT TILL DIED, WAS
KILLED, HIS MEMORIAL WAS DEFACED
AS WELL.
WHAT DOES THAT SAY TO YOU ABOUT
THE ROLE IN HISTORY YOUR BROTHER
HAS PLAYED?
>> WELL, I SAID IT BEFORE,
EMMETT TILL WAS FIRST GEORGE
FLOYD.
AND MY BROTHER, THE ONLY
DIFFERENCE IS IT WAS A CAMERA,
AND IT WAS A SIMILAR PICTURE,
EVERYBODY SEEN IT ACROSS THE
WORLD.
IT WASN'T ANY WAY YOU COULD HIDE
WHAT HAPPENED.
AND WHAT I SEE AND WHAT PEOPLE
SEE IS WE NEED TO GET EVERYTHING
TOGETHER NOW BECAUSE PEOPLE AS
AMERICANS, WE DON'T WANT TO LIVE
IN A COUNTRY WHERE WE CAN'T WALK
OUTSIDE.
WE'RE SCARED TO BE IN A VEHICLE
AT A CERTAIN TIME OF NIGHT
BECAUSE FREEDOM IS EVERYTHING.
AND IT'S HELD TO ANTICIPATE
DEATH.
NOBODY WANTS TO DO THAT.
THAT'S THE WAY THIS WORLD RIGHT
NOW IS MOVING.
WHERE AFRICAN-AMERICAN PEOPLE
WE'RE ANTICIPATING DEATH, WE GET
PULLED OVER BY POLICE OFFICERS,
WE ARE PRAYING AND HOPING THAT
WE LIVE AND THAT WE GET A GOOD
POLICE OFFICER AND NOT A BAD
ONE.
YOU HAVE GOOD ONES AND YOU HAVE
BAD ONES, YOU SHOULDN'T HAVE TO
SORT THEM OUT.
>> PHILONISE, THANK YOU FOR
JOINING US THIS MORNING AND I
WANT TO LEAVE YOU AND OUR
VIEWERS WITH THE KNOWLEDGE THAT
VOLUNTARY
VOLUNTEERS MOBILIZED VERY QUICK
THROUGH CLEAN UP THAT STATUE OF
YOUR BROTHER SO IT COULD RETURN
AS IT WAS IN UNION SQUARE.
THANK YOU FOR BEING WITH US.
>> YOU KNOW, ONE THING BEFORE I
GO --
>> MM-HMM.
>> I REALLY WANTED TO GET THIS
OUT, I THINK THAT, LIKE, I WANT
TO CALL OUT ALL THE DEMOCRATS, I
WANT ALL OF THEM TO BRING THE
GEORGE FLOYD JUSTICE AND
POLICE
ING ACT TO THE FLOOR